hey guys goodness I have a fitness app
you get to workout life with me and
other amazing trainers every single day
go on done appear on the App Store or go
to fear live.com and start your journey
to become here's another crazy intense
workout for you so what we're gonna do
today is an intense cardio kickboxing we
will be incorporating a lot of
kickboxing movement and a lot of
explosive movements okay so we're gonna
get your body warmed up and I guarantee
you you will be sweaty at the end of
this workout only 25 minutes long get
your energy up 30 seconds of work with
15 seconds of rest in between I'm scared
but do you know what let's prove through
together all right
so let's just start by warming up okay
let's just start by jogging on the spot
to begin with let's start by jogging on
the spot let's slowly bring your heart
rate up good jog on the spot and loosen
up your shoulders roll your shoulders
back and give me big arm circles back
and now forward good and now get into
forward lunge okay alternating on one
leg keep going forward lunge and now
reach up back down reach up few more
go lower okay every time we lunch go
lower
one more good and now just check it out
give me a few nice all right just give
me double knee on left side double knee
on the right side go double push your
hips forward push your hips forward and
push good so aim to drive the knees
forward drive the knees few more one
more and right now I just want you to
work on your hips mobility so just arms
by your side open up and open up okay
good that's it
so spread it out to the side very good
keep going some of you might find that
this movement is actually really tough
that means you might be tight on your
hip flexor area okay so just open up to
the side bring your knee as high as you
can
one more and shake it out
all right the first workout there will
be a total of eight exercises the first
workout will be punches with explosive
lunges so get into a fighting stance
left foot forward right foot back arms
up guard your face and give me four
punches okay lunch down explode explode
good one two three four down explode
explode good only thirty seconds of work
okay nice keep going this is your first
workout strong punches
look straight ahead hop and hop
breathe out punch left and right good
and rest it out second workout sprawl
with a front kick so what I wanted to do
is you can use the mat if you have a mat
get down into a sprawl get up into a
front kick alright ready
three seconds let's do this together
down onto the mat sprawl bring your hips
down get back up left front kick right
Frankie okay so bring your hips touching
the floor up left and right
good keep going hips down onto the floor
swing your arms back I'm sit down keep
going down left and right up so drop the
opposite I'm okay kick and kick and
shake it off
alright I told you it's gonna be a
high-energy workout so workout push up
to split lunges so again down onto your
mat okay we're working on our upper body
at this time let's get down start with a
push up and split lunge left and right
good push-up split lunge left and right
again working on your hips mobility
push-up left look up right good
halfway there if this is too challenging
you can always get down onto your knees
push up left look up and right nice
remember to breathe normally right and
back up right double knees a little bit
of cardio movement double knees so again
just like a warm-up imagining that
you're driving your hips forward okay
ready let's go
double knee driver hips forward and
switch side double push up tip to if you
can and push so drive your knees your
hips forward okay not up but forward so
drive it forward and drive it forward
good keep going whoa the other side
change
knees forward hips push your hips
forward and keep going and 15 seconds
rest wide squat palaces crisscross Stan
white toast pointed up out I want to get
low and maintain a low position three
white squat houses okay ready or not
let's go one two three crisscross two
three go there you go crossover okay
whoa whew the burn on your legs on your
glutes keep your body upright two three
crisscross good few more two more at
least two more maintain lower crisscross
and rest it out in and out squad to a
jock okay so let's start with both feet
together we're gonna jump out into a
white squad and back in and then jog it
out okay ready let's go out in jog it
out good out in jog it out good that's
it
so go low every time you squad go low
chug it up for jokes
bring your knees up in out in out in
knees up as high as you can in one more
out in last one out in and get let's get
down all right
second last workout plank walk with a
pike so start on the left side of your
mat okay
palms sugar with a pot ready let's walk
walk and take it in
pick it up walk left right pack it in
and out left and right in and out good
so one step to the left one step to the
right
nice as you pack in feel your call
working Oh straight legs as much as you
can straight legs oh you have one more
workout okay
let's do this together 180 degrees
shuffle I want you to focus on speed
nice shuffle as fast as you can so let's
start right center having go to the lab
okay so shuffle right four treys good
that's it okay go back and back
so keep twisting and shuffle okay good
keep twisting and go forward and this
side good forward and left forward few
more you're on with their left and let's
finish it rest it out one click it done
your heart rate should be way up there
grab some water drink some water
two more seconds okay no time wasted
let's do this 45 more seconds rest
my heart rate is above 150 right now and
that's the level that I want to keep it
at so between 150 to 160 okay this is a
good cardio level to burn fat and also
to just burn lots of calories 15 seconds
left first workout punches with
explosive lunges so left foot forward
right foot back arms up guarding your
face strong for punches explosive lunge
okay two explosive lunges one two back
at it let's go one two oh one keep going
find your target focus on that target
look straight ahead twist the hips move
your hips as you punch relax those
shoulders last one one more hop and rap
it off sprawl with a front kick okay so
with sprawl your goal is to bring your
hips down onto the floor touch the floor
to have the floor get back up all right
ready let's go and sprawl
don't touch left and right drop the arm
where your leg is kicking okay good
sprawl it down left and right good
remember to keeping these soft okay do
not jerk your knees up
stay strong drop your heels draw the
hips down touch the floor
cut back up I spices again and rest push
up to split lunches okay upper body
strength right now everything we thought
oh I can see my sweat slipping through
my pants already let's go push up left
look up right open up okay as you split
look up view the stretch good pickup
very nice keep going push up split one
more push up and come back up all right
double knees on the left and on the
right remember to drive your hips
forward okay I am starting I'm panting
and you should be sweating too
let's go double knee add a little hop
okay let's do Street your knees add a
little hop switch and hop drive your
hips forward
drag the knees forward good not up but
forward ten more seconds
with their you're doing so good last one
on the other side and rest it on who Oh
in advice with a criss cross let's start
with a white squad ok 3 white squad
pulses to criss cross stay low
let's go one two three criss cross to
the other side right leg forward left
leg forward
stay low very good halfway there
stay strong strong legs I know your legs
on fire mine as well chicken in and out
with a job ok so one in and out and jog
it out breathe that 15 seconds is a
precious time to just breathe well let's
go in out jog it out
jog it out good
- ease up okay here your breathing
do your hundred one more rest plank walk
- pike so let's get down onto the mat
let's finish this second set
okay let's go up left and right Pike up
we're doing this real time together
no break no stop we sweat together I
feel your burn we see results together
okay plank walk left to right and Pike
up cried your core remember my favorite
thing your sweat is your fat crying and
your effort 180 degree shuffle okay
final workout and you again a one-minute
break it should be raining right now at
your place
hasta la shuffle okay keep twisting 180
degrees
good move your arms relax our shoulders
move together okay
this is an easy workout to bring your
heart rate down halfway there
keep going forward right
was their last one rested on oh can you
see this
breathing out one minute rest final
round
don't stop when you're tired stop when
you're done okay drink some water
only 45 more seconds of eight times to
push through that's six minutes last 36
minutes okay drink some water
all right that timer says we have less
than 10 seconds left
punches with explosive lunges okay right
remember you always keep your knees bent
slightly pointed forward and let's go
punch and twist from your hips explosive
lunge punch and twist lunch deep and go
four times okay one two three four let's
go down and up breathe out as you punch
nice that's it keep going do you more
give me one more last one and sprawl
with pancakes all right
again the goal is to get your hips down
onto the floor
I still kick up swing the opposite arm
down okay got that let's go three
seconds let's get down together
let's go hips no good done again left
and right okay be careful to not jerk
your knees too much strong kicks point
your heels forward halfway there it's
brought down drop your hips come up as
fast as you can down one more upper body
push up with split lunches okay Oh see
that sweat all over all right let's go
push up okay down nice Ollie push up
split left and right good
spread it out bring your feet as close
to your palms okay down left and right
this is a really good flexibility
movement as well
one more and come back oh all right
double knees remember to add a little
bit of help okay
oh my god I'm sweating through all right
double knees let's not stop right now
start with your left and go into your
right one two okay
drive your hips forward bring your knees
forward tiptoe okay lift your heels off
the floor tiptoe and drive it ten
seconds left keep that heart rate going
switch one more switch I'm dressed white
squad pulses with criss-cross
all right then white toast points it out
okay we got this oh one two three
criss-cross two three okay if you can
challenge yourself bring the speed out
and keep alternating between sides okay
left foot forward and right foot forward
two more
ah oh my god those legs those legs okay
in and out squat and jog it out
are we ready three seconds let's go
narrow white in high knees okay or you
can just jog it out
choose your option high knee or jog it
out whoa explosive movements it's really
good to bring your heart rate up you
can't get this workout done this cardio
workout done if you're not a big fan of
running on treadmills okay that's one
and plank walk to Pike let's get down to
more workouts left only two more stay
with me
let's get down Oh breathe let's go left
right hike left right hike see that's
wet that's effort that's dedication
that's consistency okay keep going
I can walk it to the left and to the
right
guess what one will work I left and
you're done you're done okay let's go
180-degree shuffles that's not from our
left and move on - alright okay let's
add four on each side and shuffle good
swing your arms relax your shoulders and
just treat this as a coup down times I
can slap guys keep going keep twisting
last one high five
just give me a big high five right now
you have done three seconds it exercises
of crazy intense cardio kickboxing oh my
god if your sweat is dripping like mine
is if your hair is messy like mine if
you're out of breath
be sure to give this app a five-star
rating on the App Store and be sure to
share this workout and recommend this
workout to your other friends okay well
done now let's just breathe in and let's
just cool down okay breathe in and out
routine
all right let's get down to the floor
bring your left leg forward
okay drop your right knee and I want to
place it right pump on the floor and
just stretch and look up okay
just slowly breathe deep in and bring
your heart rate back down we're not
rushing to go anywhere right now look up
and now change leg right leg forward
left palm on the floor twist the other
side and just slowly drop your heart
rate
good and now bring both knees down get
into a nice Child's Pose okay
just inch forward and go lower and I'll
just bring your right hand across and
look to your left through the stretch on
your right shoulders as well as the
right back
change sides
can you just relax you're not rushing
and they'll come up slowly bring
yourself up alright we've done a lot of
lower body workouts so I want you to
just if you want to support yourself on
the wall and just stretch your quads out
okay
just stretch your quads out find a
balance release cross over and just
reach down do the stretch along your
hamstrings
and now with the right leg cross it over
and I want to just slowly bend down and
through the stretch on your glutes if
this is to top what you can do is find a
balance by touching the floor okay if
not open up your chest look straight
ahead and now let's switch the other
side left leg up stretch your quads good
find your balance
very nice oh my gosh I kind of sweat and
I'll cross over reach down
and now bring your left leg stack it on
top of your right leg find a balance and
slowly lower yourself down okay look
straight ahead and feel the stretch on
your glutes and I just twist side to
side and you're done
hold on okay this is not an easy workout
there's a lot of a lot of explosive
movement but it's a really effective
cardio workout which you can do from the
comfort of your own home or anywhere at
any time if you're sweating if your hair
is messy like me be sure to give this
video a thumbs up okay if you enjoyed
this workout don't forget that I have my
own fitness app you can check it out on
the app store called view we will be
sharing daily live workout classes with
you to get you fit active and also for
you to achieve your fitness goal
remember to share this video tag your
friends challenge them to do this
workout together with you and subscribe
to my youtube channel for a lot more
workout videos challenges fitness tips
healthy and delicious recipes and I will
see you on my next workout and guys
check this out look at that sweat this
is real again so let me know in the
comments below
even you're sweaty like me